prosecutors say they plan to file more
charges against the accused gunman
in this week's supermarket shooting in
boulder colorado that left 10 people
dead
police say the assault rifle used in the
rampage was legally
purchased jonathan vigliotti reports
26 agencies including the fbi are
retracing
ahmedalisa's steps inside this king
supers monday
removing every item from the shelves in
search of bullet casings
and any other evidence investigators are
also building
a timeline of alisa's movements before
the attack
including the legal purchase of an
assault style weapon
at this shop six days earlier any
indication as to why he chose
this supermarket 30 miles away from
where he lived
i really do wish i could tell you that
it'll be something haunting
for for all of us until we figure that
out
alisa appeared before a judge yesterday
and was moved to a more secure
correctional facility
after receiving threats meanwhile a
digital forensics team
is scouring his online activity for
clues
among the 10 dead was kevin mahoney his
daughter erica shared
this photo of him walking her down the
aisle last year
this year he was excited to welcome his
first grandchild
this little baby girl is what's getting
us through this time
because like i can feel her kick and
every kick
is telling me to be strong
for cbs this morning saturday jonathan
vigliotti boulder colorado